so my
first one
I left but it nearly cost me my life
um my second one I
it was I was seeing someone and he
was seeing other women so that ended
um and my third one I was just a huge
secret
so that ended in November
so like his family and friends didn't
know about you no okay so you felt like
you wanted something more serious and it
was more casual for him yeah I think so
um it was four years that I was with him
so
if you don't mind me asking how did you
almost lose your life in the first one
uh
domestic abuse
physical abuse
um
all abuse
yeah I was basically isolated
um
big question on live TV
yeah that's I have a counseling for it
um I've got two beautiful girls
um amazing girls who blessed me with
those
um certainly taught me a lesson huge one
um one that nearly cost me in my life
um
but yeah I was with him for a long time
I don't know why I stayed I think
mentally and emotionally I think abusers
have a way of
the physical disappears
the mental and emotional abuse stays
um
where I was so isolated from everybody
and I think in terms of
I only had him and his family so it was
quite difficult and I think
the good was good
the bad was horrific
so
um were you able to press charges
I didn't for a very long time but I
don't think
I dealt with it and healed from it until
years later
um in fact it was only up until a few
years ago so I finally left in 2010
um
so 13 years ago and I only really dealt
with it and got support for it at five
five years ago and dealt with it so I
think it was
I up and moved the police removed me
from my home
um it was going to go to court we did go
to court
um they said I wouldn't see him at court
I did see him at court and then that's
when I withdrew all my statements so he
still got prosecuted I think now they
can prosecute yeah um
but at the time that wasn't the case I
think he just he got a fine in probation
and community service and stuff like
that so
um and I think for me they told me I was
looking at five years and we had two
girls so you wanted him to not that I
wanted him back but I just thought for
the girls right but now looking back
that was the wrong decision I think he's
gone on to have multiple abusive
relationships since though but um my
girls have had nothing to do with him so
that's kind of yeah yeah my youngest one
did seek him out but
he's not changed so um she no longer
wants a relationship with him my oldest
one remembers too much
definitely doesn't want anything to do
with him at this stage but I would never
not promote that I think that's
something that they would need to make a
decision for at the time I stopped them
from having that relationship for their
own safety and mine
um I've never stopped it in terms of if
you wanted to do it
properly and on the legal route
um supervised contact absolutely but
he's never wanted to take that so
um it was all about control and and
about me so the times that he did have
contact with the girls in the early
years when I left
he would be screaming to at the girls
for them to put me on the phone so it
was never really about the girls anyway
so
so yeah so that was my first one
thank you for sharing that
um okay I'm I'm curious like how many
years were you with him before you left
was it did you say seven so from the age
of 18 to
28 oh wow wow that's a long time yeah so
just
because I'm always just curious like
when did you realize he was abusive
so it was gradual so after probably
about the first eight months seven
months eight months
um
but it was little things can't go out
didn't want me to go to work but made it
made me feel like it was I was doing
something wrong all the time having male
friends why have you got so many male
friends just yeah it's the Ice Station
why are you wearing that that doesn't
look nice on you you don't need to wear
heels today why have you got makeup on
you guys just little things
you know I come down in something that I
want to wear I don't really look nice
babe why don't go change it
little things but then obviously
past relationships his own insecurities
obviously knowing people that I had had
a relationship with previously
we could be watching telly it could be
anything that triggered him it didn't
matter what it was then
um but physically
yeah about after about seven eight
months
oh
so what what made you stay that long
good question
good question I don't know okay I don't
know the good times were good I think in
terms of
I don't have any real answer maybe I
thought I loved him I thought he loved
me
um
always sorry he would always be sorry
for the things that happened and
make things up buy things take me out
say nice things to me pillow talk I
guess if you like
um
yeah I follow in situations like that if
you don't mind me just saying what I'm
about to say but it's kind of like when
you've experienced such lulls any high
will seem like the happiest thing on
Earth for you and it will make you want
to stay so it doesn't matter like how
however long how long they've been
together how long bad stuff has been
happening but if the high is high then
you are going to stay believe it or not
it's going to take a lot of Detachment
it's going to take a lot of like
self-discipline for you to be like for
you to kind of go this High isn't the
high we want this this high is only High
because the lows have been so low I
disagree I I disagree someone that's
been a similar situation sometimes you
don't know what day the week is let
alone high as a high and it's all about
picking away at you so by the end of it
you've got no identity you must probably
just his partner and the kid's mum and
these things creep up on you I mean I
put up with it for I think less than a
year but and in my day you call the
police he was like oh it's a domestic
they've never done anything in those
days so it's probably for 10 years wow I
had police at my house now please just
come regular and just say oh it's a
domestic I need this leave and you put
hanging them in there you're supposed to
take him with you
I never did
the only most you're going to get out of
your Social Services so back then it
wasn't even that no but you didn't even
get that back there was nothing then and
I mean I didn't have my son then when I
did that my son and I thought that's it
I'm out of there yeah but it's like
especially when things happen around his
family not yours and that's the weird
thing is you feed yourself how can you
have a family and they know what's going
on but they won't do anything and then
you realize that the whole family's
scared of him yeah that's what I think
it's going to ask him was his family
kind of complicit in the abuse they knew
what was going on and they just turned a
blind eye or was it secret to them
they were aware they didn't condone it
um there was one incident where his his
mum did say that
she's the that brought him into the
world she'll be there to take him take
him out obviously but that was because
it was right in front of her
um
majority of the time I would spend time
at his mum's
um In fairness and she was amazing and
she was she's been in a great amazing
grandmother
um to the girl so
they they know their identity they know
where they come from and they know his
entire family the only person that
they've not had contact with is him
um so that's their choice as an adult
whether they want to go back there or
not
um my elders remember stuff she shared
stuff with her younger sister I've had
to try and protect her younger sister
from that but they are sisters they will
talk yeah I won't lie to them
but I don't need to divulge anymore that
it's not been said if that makes sense
so that's
how did you break it off because we know
we're talking about breaking off like
how did you actually break off I went
into a woman's Refuge okay you've done
the midnight flip I did had a bad bad
ready
the first so the first time I was
removed by the police
um they came and removed me and they
took me to my mum's but then after a few
months
I went back but there was a
normalization order in place he wasn't
allowed in certain in the area he wasn't
allowed back at the property but then as
time lapsed
two years later
I put myself back into a woman's Refuge
um and just left
and then I've never looked back and I
was like am I allowed to add a really
good judge that done an injunction out
with a clause but they wanted in order
to cancel the injunction we both have to
be at court
oh and it's 37 years late and I don't
think you realize it still standing I
mean there's no trouble now but it still
stands no I didn't I didn't he wasn't
allowed in the area but it was only for
a period of time
um I can't I think it was about six
months
um maybe even a year but he he breached
out anyway but
um when I went back the second time I
just 21st January 2010.
never look back
cut my hair changed everything about me
and stuff just feels good fresh stuff
amazing so yeah
then the second one that was a
three-year relationship but that was
wasn't really going anywhere I wasn't it
was just
something for me at the time I think I
had the girls it wasn't something that I
was really looking to commit to anyway
but
I found out he was seeing multiple women
so it just kind of ended but my last one
I do love him still
um but it's not worked out I'm not
prepared to be a secret for any longer
um C'est La Vie it is what it is we move
on did you just say right it's finished
now there's been a lot of back and forth
um
we've just not spoke
um he knows how I feel about certain
things so
we've just not communicated would you
say you like bad boys it seems like all
of the guys you pick seem to be bad boys
what's a bad boy like non-committal
multiple girls I mean usually I wouldn't
say the majority of bad boys are abusive
but in her case that would probably
qualify
I think sometimes we can pick partners
that are
possibly a reflection of how we feel
about ourselves sometimes or what we're
missing
um
I don't know I'm work I'm on I'm on a
journey at the moment I'm healing and
I'm learning a lot about myself and
about
I'm doing a lot of inner child work I'm
looking at myself going back through my
history why do I pick the men
that I have I do come from a broken home
is it generational is it one of those
things that just my upbringings impacted
that the influences around I I don't
know I'm doing a lot of work on that at
the moment because I do think it does
impact on our decision making and our
judgments
[Music]
um
how we brought up how childhood I think
it plays a huge part
[Music]
um
and how we develop just to put a smile
in your face but it's a nice question
it's still smiling she was a Christian
would you would you get to give a
vegetarian
the vegetarian yeah
you're perfect guy and he said I'm a
vegetarian
it's not perfect okay
[Laughter]
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible